police are investigating a series of  student deaths at the University of  Southern California in Los Angeles  consider this since the fall semester  began in August  nine students have died there the school  says three of those were by suicide  police are looking into whether drug  overdoses played a role in some of those  deaths the university sent a letter to  students on Tuesday warning about the  dangers of drug use particularly opioids  we do know that in many cases not at USC  but in our community  fentanyl has been mixed with other drugs  and it has led to many deaths and  overdoses hundreds of students gathered  on campus last night to talk about these  losses nine since August darling